皆さんこんばんははじめしゃちょーと
イケメンと大地とタナッチです皆さんは
鬼ごっこというものをご存知でしょうか
昔からよくある遊びで一人が
鬼になり残りの人間が
逃げるそんな鬼ごっこという遊び
昔からあるんですけれどもその鬼ごっこ
怖くより
楽しく遊べるために
ろうそく鬼ごっこというものを考えました
今日はそれをこのイカれた
仲間たちでやっていきたいと思います
澤部さんは
鬼ごっこしたことありますかないです帰っ
てくださいルール説明です
鬼が一人
逃げる人が3人最初は僕が鬼やらせて
ください全員殺しますので残りの皆さんが
人ということで
逃げてください
鬼が一人逃げる人が3人そして制限時間が
30分と今回させていただきます建物の中
を真っ暗にします
そして
ろうそくとライターがあればこの
ろうそく鬼ごっこ遊べます逃げる人3人と
鬼4人とも
ろうそくを準備してください
ここにあるの多分自体使うと思うんです
けれども人のロウソクは小さめでいいと
思いますで鬼のろうそくはちょっと太めに
してください建物の中が真っ暗なので
明かりと音だけが
頼りになりますなのでしっかりと握る人は
耳をちゃんと聞いて音と光で判断して逃げ
てください
鬼にタッチされると捕まってしまいます
これも普通の鬼ごっこと一緒タッチされた
人は
牢屋に連行されます
鬼の牢屋って場所を作ったので今回玄関に
しましょうか4件のうちのでそうやって鬼
が3人タッチしに行くので一人でも30分
が逃げ切れればあなたたちの勝ちです
シンプルなルールでここからが特徴の
ルールなんですけれども人間の皆さん
ロウソクの火が消えたらその
場で死亡です
普通の鬼ごっこだったら走ってしまうじゃ
ないですか
走った勢いで
ろうそくの火が消えてしまうとそこで死ん
でしまうんですねなのでスピードが結構気
をつけなきゃいけない
ろうそくのが消えてしまったらもうそこで
ゲームオーバーもうゲームには復帰できず
にその場でもう
ガチで死んでいただいて
鬼にタッチされてしまった人は牢屋に連行
されてしまいますで
鬼に火を消されてしまうんですけれども
連行された人はまだ死んではいないので
この仲間の力を借りて復活することができ
ます
牢屋にいる仲間は復活させるためには自分
のその持ってるろうそくで消えてしまった
仲間のろうそくもう一回火を灯すことが
できれば
復活になりますなので正直
ろうそくの火が消えなければ復活できる
チャンスあるとなぜ移動だけ気をつけるの
かちょっと逃げる側の注意点ですね制限
時間30分間こんな細いろうそくだと
持ちませんろうそくが小さくなりすぎて気
が消えてしまうとそこでもう死んでしまう
ので建物の中にローソクを何個か配置し
ときすぎて気にかけたろうそくを取り替え
ても大丈夫ですそれで命をつないで
ください次は鬼側の説明ですね
鬼は30分以内に全員捕まえるか死亡さ
せれば勝ちです鬼もろうそく持ってます
鬼のろうそくの火が消えても
鬼は死にませんただタッチしても人を殺せ
なくなってしまいますそんな鬼のために
このライターも建物の中に何個か置いて
ありますライターを持ち運びできずにその
場でつけるだけなんですけど再び火を
つければまた鬼タッチされると人を
捕まえることができるとなので鬼の
ろうそくちょっと大きいんですけれども
それでもやっぱり消えないようにした方が
いいというのがこのゲームになってます
どうですか今のところルールが
バッチリです
全く分かりません
簡単に言うと
ローソクを火を消しちゃダメな鬼ごっこ
ですね多分部屋くらいがめちゃくちゃ怖い
と思うんだよそれを是非はみんなでやって
みたいと思いますはい最後にこの
鬼ごっこ一番怖いところがあります
火のインカです小さな炎であったとしても
何かに引火してしまって
火災に繋がるかもしれないそれだけは気を
つけて安全にプレイしていきましょうと
いうわけでまずは私はじめしゃちょーが鬼
そしてあなたたち3人が逃げてください
めっちゃ火つけます
では皆さん3分後にやりましょういっ
てらっしゃい
[音楽]
こっちですぐ消えちゃいそう
待って本当に怖い
[音楽]
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
どうも
鬼ですこの館にいる全ての人間を殺します
早速行きましょうか1987654321
[音楽]
ろうそく鬼ごっこ開始
さあどこにいる
これちょっと
怖いんだけど
[音楽]
どこだ
明るい部屋発見
これあの鬼も消す時慎重にいかないと
効力なくなっちゃうので
1階にはさすがにいなそうだな
結構天才かも
次はどこに行こうかな
[音楽]
やばいやばい
[拍手]
人はいるか
やばいやばいやばい
消えた
死んだ
3階からは靴を脱がなければいけないお前
3回か4階にいるな
ぁ
どこにいる
やばいエアコンエアコンが強くて火消える
ダメだエアコンが強くて火消える
ここにはいない
エレベーター使ってみようかな
[音楽]
エレベーターに乗って馬で行こうかな行く
ぞ
階へ行くぞ
[音楽]
大丈夫か
3回は
狭いぞ
見つけ
騙されたエレベーターにエレベーターに
騙されたみたいだなでもこっから逃げ切れ
ばいい
じゃないもう
罪だ
[拍手]
この家の構造的にねちょっと3階は苦しい
ですか
一人
捕まえた
ここで休んでなさい
死んでる
[音楽]
多分自爆したんだろうなまあこういうこと
が起きるのか
ろうそく鬼ごっこ
もうお世話料は復活不可能
が来たら助かる可能性があります
あとは
助けて
[音楽]
あと一人だ
どこだ
たなっちのことだから
助けに行きそうだなもう1回とかにいるん
じゃないのか
どこにいる
この部屋
いない
どこだ
助けは来ない
のことだから
助けに行きはするんだろうなぁ
なっちーさん
どこでまあまだ行ってない4階に行き
ましょうか
階に来る音がしてるので
逃げました
4回に来ました
よね
間に合うか間に合うか間に合うかこれ
間に合うから
これ行ったな
やばい
急げ急げ
[音楽]
生き返ったぞ
やばいやばい
助かったやつがいるというのか
許せない
[音楽]
このまま4回
逃げ込みます
[音楽]
許せない
終わった
[音楽]
助けて
大地君がいたということはまだ1回か2階
にいる
飛べるようにして1階に行きます
[音楽]
ちゃんといるだろうなちょっと
守りを怠ったところあったからだ
大丈夫だよなそして一人は死んでいる
大丈夫
ここからどうするかですね私は
4階に行くリスクすごいね
[音楽]
そしてこのフィールドエレベーターが相当
鍵になってると見た
処理時間15分といったところか半分か
行くぞ
攻めと守りを分けなければ
[音楽]
な意外と1階に隠れていたりしないのか
もう
[音楽]
[拍手]
終わった
やばいやばい
いや待って待ってこれこのまま待てば寿命
が尽きるのではやばいやばいな
助けていく読みで待っていたんだなぁ
[音楽]
ろうそくを見ようもうないぞ
全滅だ
はいというわけでどうでした
あなたは
助けに行ってたんですけどちょっと
エレベーターの時ですねこのステージ
逃げ場がないね広いからね逆にもしかし
たら外に行くのはかなり手かもしれない逆
にねちょっと2回戦目は
詳しいので
鬼として残りさんに俺とサービスでやって
いきたいと思いますはいモード入って
もらう
逃げます
やばい
[音楽]
空調で消えそうになる
これねマジで
喋ってるとね消える
自爆だけ気をつけろよ
次どこ行こう
行きます
[音楽]
どこにいる
どこだ
[音楽]
笑っちゃダメだよ
音が聞こえたどこにいる
[音楽]
ここか
どこだ
[音楽]
見つけたやばい
[笑い]
[音楽]
絶対逃げる
待て
やばい
消えそう
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
[音楽]
おらおらおらおら
待って
消えた
あと二人
[音楽]
どこどこだ
この家のことは一番知ってるぞ
[音楽]
どこにいる
僕にいる
[音楽]
いる
今今足音聞こえなかったここえっいない
じゃん
怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い何本当に待っ
てる足音聞こえたと思ったのに
本当に
ここか
いないちょっとあれ今の
ちょっと待ってここやめよ怖いこのこのが
やめます
怖いんで洗います
4階だ
あ音が聞こえたぞ4
階か
いるんだろう
[音楽]
どこだ
痛い
[音楽]
よ
[拍手]
[音楽]
俺はねちっこいぞー
追っかけるぞ
待って
[拍手]
初めて
どこ行ったあれ
死んでる
急げ
過ぎた
あと一人だ
残り20分
牢屋の二人はねもう生き返ることがない
からあとはたなっちを見つけるだけ
1階だな
[音楽]
死んでるかちゃんと
痛い
[音楽]
終わった
待って
[拍手]
楽しい
[音楽]
捕まえずみんな死んじゃった